[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d'attali
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui
philippe corcuff pour son essai la
grande confusion
comment l'extrême droite gagne la
bataille des idées
lucile peytavin qui publie le coût de la
virilité ce que la france économiserait
si les hommes se comportait comme les
femmes et ariane bois pour son roman
l'amour au temps des éléphants et on
commence tout de suite à notre époque
qu'est ce qui caractérise ce début de
xxième siècle voici vos réponses en
images on commence par la vôtre ariane
bois c'est une une récente du quotidien
libération alors pourquoi celle-ci parce
que j'ai trouvé l'histoire est
incroyable et l'anc est plutôt bien
faite sur une mode une mode qui concerne
les animaux sauvages
les lionceaux les tigres que l'on
photographie avec qui l'on pose et qui
nous vient de dubaï et qui arrive
maintenant évidemment en france et qui
paraît comme ça anodine mais qui en fait
est un trafic d'animaux sauvages parce
que ce magnifique lons où il va grandir
et il sera abandonné ou affamés ou
martyrisé et c'est donc quelque chose
qui me touche dont j'ai essayé aussi de
parler
finalement à travers mon roman on
parlera tout à l'heure effectivement de
deux d'amour et de liberté des animaux
sauvages votre image a voulu s'il
peytavin c'est simone de beauvoir et oui
moi je reste dans le thème du 8 mars et
de la journée internationale des droits
des femmes
donc c'est une photo qui a été prise en
1944 par robert doisneau lorsqu'elle
travaille au café des deux magots et je
voulais plus particulièrement abordé le
deuxième sexe qu'elle publie quelques
années plus tard donc en 1949 et
rappeler à quel point c'est un livre un
ouvrage qui est fondamental pour penser
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
puisque lorsqu'elle a commencé à rédiger
elle voulait parler de son vécu de
femmes et finalement elle a étudié la
place des femmes dans la société
que ce soit dans la sphère privée ou
publique et en s'appuyant sur de
nombreuses études scientifiques dont
quelque part elle a fait une marque et
au logis des études féminines
qui ont suivi et qui ont étudié la
question de la place des femmes dans la
société à l'aune de la question de genre
et ça c'était tout à fait inédit et le
second apport que l'on connaît tous mais
qui s'incarne dans cette phrase on ne
naît pas femme on le devient
elle aurait pu aussi dire on ne naît pas
homme on le devient
et elle déconstruit à ce moment là
l'idée qui est l'idée prédominante à
l'époque qui est que les hommes et les
femmes sont destinés à avoir une vie en
fonction de leur sexe biologique et
notamment pour les femmes une vie liés à
la maternité est ce qu elle rappelle là
c'est que nous sommes finalement hommes
et femmes des êtres humains avant tout
et que nous sommes d'abord défini par
les expériences et par la vie que l'on
mène ce n'est pas du tout linverse et
cette idée elle est au fondement donc du
féminisme qui veut l'égalité entre des
êtres qui sont égaux et ce n'est
absolument pas donc une guerre des sexes
comme on l'entend souvent mais bien une
guerre des femmes et des hommes qui le
sont contre le sexisme et pour l'égalité
et enfin l'image que vous avez choisi
vous philippe corcuff c'est un tableau
un tableau du 19e siècle c'est la tamise
pain alors je vous laisse je voulais
sans faire la description
oui c'est un tableau de claude monet un
qui me semble bien retraduire le
brouillard idéologique intellectuelle et
politique dans lequel on est alors il ya
plusieurs tableaux de monet et a souvent
des tableaux sur le brouillard à la
campagne mais là on est à londres
et donc on est dans la ville on est dans
le monde moderne on est dans le monde
urbain et se dessine quand même je pense
qu'il ya quelque chose the d'optimiste
là se dessine à travers ce pont qui
traverse la tamise la possibilité un
chemin quand même la possibilité d'une
boussole donc c'est pas une vision
complètement pessimiste disons du
brouillard actuelle eh bien on va parler
tout de suite du brouillard actuelle
avec vous la grande confusion
on commence tout de suite
[Musique]
philippe caure que vous êtes sociologue
vous enseignez à sciences po lyon vous
avez beaucoup écrit sur la philosophie
politique
aujourd'hui vous publié chez textuel la
grande confusion comment l'extrême
droite gagne la bataille des idées
c'est un gros livre de 650 pages qui
recense les traces d'extrême droite
isation idéologique aussi bien à gauche
qu'à droite et même à l'extrême gauche
cela se traduit d'après vous par des
tendances identitaire de l'ultra
conservatisme du conspirationnisme ou un
président de la république comme
emmanuel macron pas identitaire pour un
sou pendant sa campagne présidentielle
qui se retrouvent ensuite aimante et
dites vous pas les thèmes d'extrême
droite pour des raisons tactiques
alors le progressisme et ses valeurs
émancipatrice avait le pouvoir culturel
en france on peut dire jusque dans les
années 80 il se serait incliné
aujourd'hui devant les réactionnaires
comme on les appelle en tout cas dans
l'espace public je ne crois pas à la
thèse de la droitisation de la société
la société beaucoup plus composites
ambivalente mouvante mais dans les
espaces publics politiciens médiatique
sur internet et sur les réseaux sociaux
il y a une dynamique ultra conservatrice
qui d'une certaine façon fait suite à un
certain affaissement d'un clivage qui a
marqué la vie politique le clivage
gauche droite qui né en france à la fin
du xviiie siècle pendant la révolution
française qui chemine tout doucement au
19e qui devient à partir du 20e siècle
en france le la lecture principale de
l'espace politique et qui même à un
succès mondial puisque ça devient une
façon de penser la politique au niveau
mondial aussi et depuis le début du
xxième siècle depuis le milieu des
années 2000
il ya un affaissement ce clivage
notamment à cause de l'affaissement des
deux piliers qui l'emportait le pilier
communiste et le pilier social démocrate
au niveau mondial et par rapport à ça il
ya un espace libre qui se crée avec de
nouveaux bricolage d hybridation des
choses étranges
qui sont pas complètement stabilisé mais
qui pour l'instant accroissent le
brouillard dans lequel on est situé
alors ce qu'il est intéressant
évidemment c'est de se poser la question
comment s'est opérée ce renversement à
quel moment
par quel par quels moyens et ce qui est
original dans votre livre c'est qu'à la
fois vous allez le chercher chez des
politiques que ce soit la nouvelle
droite d'alain de benoist ou le
chevènementiste le chevènementisme
pardon et mais aussi dans des émissions
de télévision comme les guignols de
l'info sur canal + où tout le monde en
parle animée par thierry ardisson ou
dans une certaine critique des médias à
la fois chez pierre bourdieu et chez
serge halimi par exemple oui parce qu'il
ya un la montée de l'ultra conservatisme
les la dimension de confusion
aujourd'hui n'est n'est pas un complot
c'est en fait à un moment donné de
manière aléatoire
l'agrégation de choses assez diverses
qui se sont connectés dans une
conjoncture dans cette conjoncture
d'affaissement du clivage gauche droite
est donc dans ce que j'appelle les
laboratoires du confusionnisme et de
l'ultra conservatisme montre choses des
choses très anciennes comme une pensée
politique d'alain de benoist qui vient
du racisme classique puis qui va
participer à à mettre en évidence une
forme de racisme identitarisme
différentialiste 10e mais s'intéresse
que ils seraient pas d'accord avec vous
s'il était là il est venu dans cette
émission d'ailleurs alain benoit il n'y
verrais pas du racisme
oui c'est pierre andré taguieff qui a
bien montré comment il y avait une
transmutation du racisme biologique à ce
qu'il a appelé le racisme
différentialiste c'est-à-dire un
essentialisme qui s'appuie sur les
cultures et non pas sur la biologie et
est donc c'est un des pères fondateurs
de l'identité harris mais avec une
grande je le dis avec une grande
curiosité intellectuelle
il a amalgamé des pensées qui viennent
de l'extrême droite la droite et des
morceaux de gauche dans la revue dont il
éléments dont il est le nom qui fait
l'éditorial on est on peut voir des
numéros sur marx sur la décroissance sur
l'anarchisme et cetera donc une des
formes très composite et il a été d'une
certaine façon un élément de laboratoire
le chevènementisme c'est autre chose
c'est j'ai moi-même été militant donc le
livre est un travail sur moi même de ce
qu'on appelle crs dont jean pierre
chevènement était un des animateurs à la
fin de descente 10e début des années 80
et il ya un moment donné face au
désarroi qui suit l'adoption d'une
politique néo-libérale par la gauche
jean pierre chevènement va chercher le
logiciel républicains peu à peu va se
mettre en place une idéologie qu'on peut
appeler nationale républicaine qui au
début vient de la gauche comme réponse à
la crise du socialisme et qui va se
diffuser à droite et à l'extrême droite
1 1 elisabeth lévy et eric zemmour
florian philippot ont une connexion à un
moment donné au début avec le
chevènementisme mais la production
intellectuelle ne se produit pas
simplement avec des chais des
politiciens chez des intellectuels mais
aussi dans les formes de culture
populaire et donc c'est pour ça que il
est très intéressant de s'arrêter sur la
routinisation la familiarisation avec
une dénonciation conspirationnistes qui
ressemble à la critique du capitalisme
mais qui est plutôt complotistes qu'on
trouve dans les guignols de l'info
notamment à travers la world company et
monsieur sylvestre et il est intéressant
de voir dans les émission d'ardisson
thierry ardisson comment une une culture
de la transgression se met en place et
une valorisation des identités aussi
tout ça n'est pas en rapport il n'y a
pas de complot il n'y a pas de connexion
mais à un moment donné ces éléments qui
sont dans un laboratoire vont se
connecter plus ou moins en créant ce que
pierre bourdieu appelle une
orchestration sans chef d'orchestre et
il s'est alors jetée dans la critique
des médias aussi bien de bourdieu ou de
serge halimi dans son célèbre livre les
nouveaux chiens de garde ce serait quoi
ce serait la dénonciation d'une forme
d'élitisme ou du mois de l'élite plus
exemple je vois sur le même plan
je met pas sur le même plan la critique
des médias de bourdieu et d'halimi
j'essaye de montrer au contraire qu' il
ya un malentendu
alors assez les deux livres sur la
télévision et les nouveaux chiens de
garde sont publiant la même collection
celle de bourdieu
mais on a d'un côté une critique
structurelle des médias ou bourdieu met
en évidence comment des gens qui croient
être opposés ont des formes de
socialisation
un inconscient de classe proches parmi
les journalistes et donc c'est ce qu'il
appelle connivence c'est à dire c'est
une mise en rapport mais qui n'est pas
consciente et chez halimi cette vision
de la connivence mute vers le copinage
et donc vers la manipulation et est donc
vers la conspiration est donc une grande
partie de la critique manichéenne des
médias tels qu'al a pu en mettre en
place dans le monde diplomatique ou dans
des journaux comme plpl ou le plan b à
un moment donné va mettre l'accent sur
une dimension simplement manipulatoire
et d'une certaine façon va faire oublier
les la structure des rapports sociaux
les rapports de classe les logiques du
capitalisme les rapports de domination
raciale les rapports de domination
masculine et cetera au profit d'une
vision en août superficiel en terme de
manipulation et tout ça ça va nourrir ce
que j'appelle l'hyper criticisme
contemporain c'est à dire quelque chose
qui est très critique qu'on voit sur
internet et sur les réseaux sociaux qui
paraît très critique très proche de
cette critique radicale de la société
capitaliste
mais en fait qu'à une critique
superficielle qui une critique que de ce
qu'ils appelaient le politiquement
correct et qui va insister sur les
manipulations consciente et les complots
et y en a dix ans une destruction de de
la critique par elle même or un des
tuyaux rhétorique principaux de
l'ultrafond si racisme et du
conspirationnisme chez alain soral chez
eric zemmour 1 dans la théorie du grand
emplacement c'est juste justement le
toit le tuyau conspirationnistes corcuff
le terrorisme islamiste a quand même
joué un rôle très important dans ce que
vous appelez l'aimantation vers les
réflexes d'extrême droite alors que ce
soit le réflexe sécuritaire identitaire
complotistes nationalistes ou manichéen
tout simplement il faut faire accords
sur yahia il ya plusieurs choses
1 la gauche elle a été paralysée
aujourd'hui elle est paralysée
intellectuellement intellectuels de
gauche et organisations parce que chacun
une vue partielle des problèmes des
enjeux contemporains
il ya une partie de la gauche qu'on
appelle républicaine qui voit bien qu'il
ya un risque islamo conservateur elle
distingue mal d'ailleurs à fait souvent
d amalgame entre l'islam au
conservatisme légaliste par exemple qui
est aujourd'hui au pouvoir depuis
longtemps au maroc qui vous dirige le
gouvernement marocain et cetera et puis
le djihadisme meurtrier bon il ya
souvent un amalgame disons médiatique
entre les deux mais ce sont deux
adversaires de l'émancipation
elle voit ça et elle voit la montée de
l'antisémitisme mais elle voit pas elle
ni même sous parfois l'existence de
l'islamophobie
il ya une autre partie de la gauche plus
radicale qui voit bien les problèmes de
l'islamophobie de la diabolisation de
l'islam dans l'espace public mais qui du
coup ne voit plus les islamo
conservatrice mme et minorent à la
question de l'antisémitisme et c'est une
un des mécanismes de paralyser de la
gauche par rapport à cette montée de
l'ultra conservatisme
si bien que finalement c'est l'autre
gauche l'ennemi principal là dedans on
alimente les visions identitarisme du
monde et on n'arrive pas à saisir disons
la globalité des enjeux contemporains
mais il pouvait-on faire l'économie des
questions d'identité et particulièrement
d'identité nationale alors que la
mondialisation des échanges et les
migrations ont changé au cours des vingt
trente dernières années ça a changé
notre pays il ya eu deux différentes
réponses par rapport à ça la réponse
disons initiale du mouvement
altermondialiste notamment en france et
ce qui va faire que très vite au lieu de
simples et anti globalisation anti
mondialisation comme dans le reste du
monde d'ailleurs aux états unis on dit
plutôt anti globalisation que
altermondialisme il ya l'idée qui s'est
dessiné d'un autre monde possible
c'est à dire il s'agit pas de défendre
la nation tout le monde mais il s'agit
d'un autre monde et donc c'était la
réponse à la mondialisation capitaliste
et néolibérale d'une relance de ce que
quand appelé le cosmopolitisme et marx
l'internationalisme et 7
cet aspect là disons finalement n'a pas
tenu et ce sont plutôt les thèmes de la
solution nationale qui sont venus de
différents éléments de l'extrême droite
de la droite et de fraction de la gauche
de forme modérée d'ailleurs aux formes
radicales
ça veut pas dire qu'il faut pas intégré
la nation dans tout ça mais on est dans
un mouvement idéologique ou si on écoute
bien les discours aussi bien les
discours d'eric zemmour que d'alain
soral mais très éloigné les discours de
frédéric lordon et puis entre les deux
un discours comme celui de jacques sapir
1 qui prône une alliance entre la gauche
radicale et l'extrême droite
et bah il ya une valorisation de la
nation comme seule solution est une
dévalorisation de tout ce qui est monde
alors qu'on pourrait tout à fait penser
d'autres accrochages entre le local les
identités souvent un son local et il ya
une très grande importance des entités
locales locale s'est pas nationale il ya
des identités locales
il ya le niveau national et le gall au
niveau mondial un mouvement comme le
mouvement zapatiste un qui à un moment
donné été popularisé par le sous
commandant marcos
il articule l'identité indigènes du
chiapas le drapeau mexicain et
l'organisation de rencontres inter
galactique de l'humanité avec
l'importance de l'humanité comme comme
horizon universalisable donc je ne
plaide pas pour la négation de la nation
mais contre ce manichéisme aujourd'hui
qui domine et qui veut des valoriser
tout ce qui est mondial et valoriser ce
qui est national je prône d'autres
accrochages entre le local et national
et le mondial philippe corcuff sur le
complotisme dont la rhétorique est
utilisé aujourd'hui par à peu près par
une grande grande partie de la société y
compris au gouvernement on l'a vu
récemment sur l'islamo gauchisme il y
avait une véritable rhétorique
complotistes qui était l'oeuvre nom
pourrait presque dire le complotisme
c'est comme la maladie infantile de
notre époque le monde s'étant
complexifier ce une manière de le
simplifier
en quoi aujourd'hui était encore pour
vous bien que partagé y compris par les
anti complotistes en quoi est elle
encore pour vous synonyme d'extrême
droite isation idéologique le
complotisme est très large dans ses
origines et dans ses utilisations c'est
une forme moderne puisque il émarge
principalement au xviiie siècle un c il
faut se débarrasser de l'idée que le
dieu est responsable de tous pour penser
que c'est des humains qui manipulent
dans l'ombre qui font que ce qui arrive
est donc une des premières formes de
complotisme c'est
la dénonciation de la révolution
française comme complot franc maçon
c'est une des premières formes apprend
après au 19e siècle viendront les formes
de conspirationnistes antisémites etc
il ya une grande diversité et on peut
dire que dans l'espace politiciens
notamment quand les politiciens soient
en difficulté quand nicolas sarkozy est
en difficulté quand jean luc mélenchon
est en difficulté quand le président de
la république
emmanuel macron est en difficulté il ya
un recours facile au schéma complotistes
et donc il est assez large
le complotisme il est faux du point de
vue de l'analyse pour quelqu'un des
sciences sociales c'est à dire que c'est
il faut distinguer les complots du
théorie du complot il ya des complots
dans l'histoire c'est à dire des
manipulations cacher le complotisme où
les théories du complot c'est de dire
que l'explication principale d'un
événement ou des processus historiques
c'est la manipulation cacher alors que
pour un chercheur en sciences sociales
et il ya toujours plusieurs facteurs en
interaction pour expliquer un événement
est un processus
donc il est faux du point de vue
intellectuel le complotisme pourquoi il
participe à l'extrême droite isation
parce que dans cette logique disons de
monter des thèmes ultraconservateur ces
thèmes sont montés à travers cette forme
on peut la théorie du grand remplacement
renaud camus on trouve des formes de
complotiste et l'exil zemmour c'est
alain soral et c'est le cadre ultra que
l'extrême droite idéologique et
fortement complotistes elle sa critique
passe par la dénonciation de
manipulation cachés par des personnes
non et elle correspond à un effacement
d'un pilier intellectuelle qui a été
celui de la gauche depuis la fin du
xviiie siècle c'est l'association entre
nous critique sociale structurelles et
l'émancipation
c'est à dire la technique sociales
structurelles c'est de dire que
évidemment il peut y avoir des
manipulations etc
mais il ya des structures de classe il
ya des structures de domination sexiste
acial et cetera qui sont hors de la
conscience même qu'ils sont des formes
un personnel le complotisme d'une
certaine façon c'est de penser la vie
le monde social comme un film
d'espionnage quant à james bond
alors que la critique des sciences
sociales elle est proche d'une série
comme les films de matrix 1 c'est à dire
une machinerie un personnel ou encore
comme skynet 1 le robot de la série des
terminators ce sont des machineries un
personnel qui est un sort nos vies c'est
ça que permet de voir la critique
sociale structurel et le complotisme lui
a une vision assez simpliste de du
blockbuster américain
bon comme cette rhétorique complotistes
a servi de et sert encore de mon amour
aux montées de l'ultra conservatisme et
du confusionnisme et ben tout petit
élément quand jean luc mélenchon pour se
sortir d'une difficulté alors qu'il ya
des perquisitions dans ces organisations
politiques
quant à emmanuel macron essayer de
sortir d'une difficulté techniquement
pendant la sphère benalla d'abord et
puis après on joue plus récemment avec
la sphère du l'islamo gauchisme ont
recours à ce petit peptide politicienne
le nez dans le guidon
mais on s'aperçoit pas qu'on légitime
une forme rhétorique qui sert
principalement à l'extrême droite
isation aujourd'hui clip donc c'est la
même chose pendant la hausse était de la
même chose pendant l' affaire strauss
kahn qui a vu le développement du
conspirationnisme dans les milieux
socialistes
c'est un livre très riche de l'édifice
650 pages il est absolument passionnant
il est très très original philippe
corcuff j'ai une dernière question parce
qu'il nous reste 2 minutes 30 avant la
pause
l'épidémie de kovy d' on l'a bien vu
depuis un an maintenant ça pourrait
aboutir à une gauchisation de la société
française il ya plein de valeurs qui
sont véhiculés qui pourraient être des
valeurs de gauche des valeurs
progressistes mais ça peut aussi tourner
à une extrême droite isation en tout cas
sous la forme
je serais quelque voulez vous la
dénoncer alors on va vers quoi
aujourd'hui d'après vous les deux sont
des tendances 1
il ya la réévaluation de la question de
la santé les gouvernements qu'ils
étaient des gouvernements néolibéraux
ont de fait abandonner les politiques
néolibérales puisqu'une valorise
maintenant les déficits budgétaires et
et injecte énormément d'argent public
dans l'économie donc c'est contraire à
tout ce qu'on nous disait il ya encore
un an un an et demi 1
il y a un souci pour les questions
écologiques et c'est donc pour le mode
de vie donc il ya des choses qui sont
intéressantes et qui pourrait aller vers
une possibilité d'émancipation
et puis il ya eu une épidémie en même
temps de conspirationnisme qui est très
forte à une remontée encore une fois de
l'antisémitisme et le racisme anti
asiatique et c'est toute une série de
visions du monde 1 avec des méchants
élite qui manipulent les personnes et et
est donc ça le succès par exemple de
quelqu'un comme raul tu as un moment
donné mais il faut savoir que le se
succédera août banquiers c'est un peu
affaissé depuis jean-luc mélenchon une
partie de la droite le président de la
république ont été le chercher un et on
légitime est d'une certaine façon ces
discours bon donc là évidemment dans la
sphère la sphère la plus dynamique en ce
moment après un an d'épidémie c'est
plutôt les formes ultra conservatrice
alors que dans la première phase du
confinement avaient émergé des
possibilités d'alternatives
alors c'est sans doute encore en jeu
mais je suis assez pessimiste
le livre s'intitule la grande confusion
comment l'extrême droite gagne la
bataille des idées ça vient de paraître
chez textuel ont fait une pause on se
retrouve juste après
[Musique]
lucile peytavin vous êtes historienne
spécialiste du travail des femmes
membres du laboratoire de l'egalité vous
publiez votre premier effet le coût de
la virilité
c'est chez anne carrière c'est sous
titré ce que la france et que de miserey
si les hommes se comportait comme les
femmes
voilà une idée vraiment original et il y
en a pas tous les jours alors comment
est ce qu'elle vous est venue alors moi
ça fait longtemps que je m'intéresse aux
différences entre les hommes et les
femmes dans la société
demain de par mon parcours
professionnels universitaires et
associatifs
et justement en me documentant sur ces
sujets là un jour je suis tombé sur une
statistique qui m'a laissé bouche bée
qui est que la population carcérale
masculine en france représentent 96 % du
total et donc je me suis demandé qu'est
ce que ça voulait dire de la violence
dans notre société qu'est ce que ça
voulait dire de la délinquance et de la
criminalité des hommes dans notre
société et en creusant un peu voilà je
me suis rendu compte qu'il représentait
83% des mis en cause par la justice 90%
des personnes condamnées par la justice
96 % donc de la population carcérale et
que si on regarde par type d'infraction
ils sont surreprésentés dans tous les
types d'infractions et notamment les
plus graves
voilà on peut encore citer quelques
chiffres 86% des auteurs de meurtres 99%
des auteurs de viol 84% des auteurs
d'accidents mortels de la route etc etc
et donc une fois que j'avais ces
chiffres à ma portée lorsque j'ai vu
dans la rue comme tout un chacun des
services de secours se déplacent et je
me suis dit que c'était probablement un
homme qui avait commis l'infraction
puisque bien je dis bien que si tous les
hommes ne sont pas meurtrier délinquants
l'immense majorité donc des meurtriers
et des délinquants ce sont des hommes on
l'a vu à travers ses chiffres et donc je
me suis dit qu'il y avait effectivement
des services de secours des services de
santé s'il y avait des victimes
également de la justice qui se met en
place la police il y à une enquête et
caetera et caetera et donc je me suis
dit que tous
la avait un coût qui devait être
faramineux et qui n'avait jamais calculé
et c'est comme ça que j'en suis venu à
donc écrire cet essai le coût de la
virilité
vous avez on peut ajouter d'ailleurs à
toutes les infractions que vous énumérez
dans lesquels dont les hommes sont à
plus de 80% responsable vous pouvez
ajouter aussi concernant la santé on
ferait une une grosse économie
si les hommes se comportait comme les
femmes puisque le taux de mortalité
évitable dites-vous est trois fois plus
élevé chez les hommes que chez les
femmes
alors qu'est ce que c'est il faut
rappeler ce que c'est que le taux de
mortalité évitable
alors effectivement les femmes les
hommes pardon ont trois fois plus de
risques que les femmes de mourir
prématurément c'est à dire avant 65 ans
et de façon enfin d'une mort évitable
c'est-à-dire induite par un comportement
à risque puisque on voit en effet que
les hommes ont des rapports pathologique
beaucoup plus important avec l'alcool
avec la vitesse avec la drogue ils se
mettent davantage en danger que les
femmes justement pour prouver qu'ils
sont des hommes forts qui peuvent
affronter la mort symboliquement mais
aussi physiquement et c'est pour cela
que effectivement on pourrait faire des
économies au niveau des services de
santé s'ils se comportaient comme les
femmes alors le total du ce que vous
appelez le coût de la virilité vous
l'avais estimée à 95 milliards d'euros
c'est beaucoup beaucoup d'argent ça
représente le déficit de l'état en 2010
9 avant la crise du coc vide c'était 93
milliards d'euros et demi donc voilà
c'est ce que coûterait ces comportements
qu'on pourrait que vous qualifiez de
typiquement masculin mais qu'est ce qui
nous rend lucile pétole aussi agressif
d'après vous il reste que c'est la
testostérone est ce que c est ce que
c'est dans le cerveau est ce que c'est
est-ce que ça remontera aux cases berne
quand on allait chasser le mammouth
alors je tiens à rassurer les hommes qui
nous écoutent ils le sont les hommes ne
sont pas violents par nature il ya des
hommes qui sont tout à fait pacifique
qui le seront toutes leurs vies et
effectivement la science a largement
démontré que c'était une construction
culturelle
vous parlez donc du temps des cavernes
où on légitime bien souvent les rôles
des hommes et des femmes dans la société
en évoquant ce fameux temps du
paléolithique
or les études de paléo l'histoire
récente montre que c'était une société
qui était relativement égalitaire dans
lesquels les femmes aussi chasser
qu'elle ne passait pas leur temps à
s'occuper des petits et que c'est
véritablement au néolithique donc vers
moins douze mille avec l'avènement de
l'agriculture et la sédentarisation
qu'il y a eu un basculement dans les
inégalités sociales et les inégalités
entre les hommes et les femmes et la
virilité s'est incarné à ce moment là
pour les hommes dans les armes en métal
qu'ils utilisaient notamment donc
finalement cet état de domination est
une construction culturelle qui n'a pas
toujours été et qu'on peut déconstruire
et également vous parliez de la
testostérone donc on n'y coupe pas c'est
effectivement l'argument qu'on avance
très souvent or là aussi les dernières
études de biologie montre que chez un
même individu des taux de testostérone
élevé par don peuvent provoquer aussi
bien des comportements altruistes que
pacifique donc la testostérone
n'explique en rien cela ni le cerveau
les études là aussi de neurologie sont
très claires et d'ailleurs les hommes
sont responsables de leurs actes puisque
quand on les juge face à la justice
on les reconnaît comme pleinement
responsables de leurs actes donc sur
cette question là
il n'y a pas de débat alors donc ce
serait à problèmes d'éducation au fond
c'est ce que vous dites dans votre livre
trop de football trop de bugs trop de
super héros trop de bagarres trop de
jouets guerriers trop de compétition
trop de transgression trop de vitesse il
faudrait dites vous que l'état s'arrête
par exemple de sponsoriser les sport
viril enfin ce que vous qualifiez de
sport viril
voilà ce serait déjà un pas en fait ce
serait de la prévention oui alors
effectivement les sciences de
l'éducation ont montré que si les
garçons les hommes se comporte comme
deux comme ça c'est dû à leur éducation
qui repose sur ses valeurs viriles par
exemple quand les garçons naissent dès
les premiers jours de la vie les parents
l'entourage valorise chez eux leur force
leur puissance ils ont moins de contact
physique avec eux qu'avec les filles
il leur parle moins en développant leur
sentiment que les filles également très
rapidement au ouaki à la violence qui
s'immisce dans les jeux de bagarres de
bataille avec des armes factices
et puis il ya la culture les livres les
films qui montrent que l'immense
majorité des héros sont des hommes qui
s'adonnent à une violence qui est
légitime et les études montrent que les
garçons développe une appétence très tôt
pour cette violence et s'identifient à
ces personnages là et puis il ya
également le moment de l'adolescence qui
à un moment de cristallisation dans la
construction de cette identité viril où
les garçons par un vocabulaire assez
orduriers on peut le reconnaître vont
rejeter ben ce qu'ils considèrent comme
faibles comme efféminé comme où les
homosexuels par exemple et puis ils vont
par exemple se donner des coups pour
montrer qu'ils résistent à la douleur
voilà qu'ils sont des hommes virils et
des hommes forts et on voit comme ça
effectivement qu'il ya toute une
acculturation une assimilation des
garçons et des hommes à la violence tout
au long de leur vie
mais si le portrait assez son bras il
faut bien le
je reconnaître que vous êtes en train de
faire d'eux des garçons est vrai la mode
aujourd'hui c'est de glorifier le
football féminin où la boxe féminine y
compris chez les féministes aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que eux
les féministes veulent pas du tout que
les que les hommes se comportent comme
les femmes elles veulent que les femmes
se comportent comme les hommes elles
vont à l'encontre de ce que vous dites
effectivement et pour moi c'est un
problème c'est à dire qu'on valorise
dans notre société les comportements
viril
c'est vrai on a de moins en moins de
problèmes à inscrire une petite fille au
football ou à la boxe qui est très à la
mode chez les femmes
par contre il y a une résistance autour
des valeurs viriles du côté des garçons
je prends souvent cet exemple on est en
2021 et on ne peut toujours pas mettre
un tee shirt rose à un petit garçon
ça paraît anodin et pourtant c'est
révélateur des résistances qu'il ya
autour de ça et dans un même mouvement
et ça c'est très important de le
comprendre le de la dévalorisation de
tout ce qui est dit féminin et pourtant
quand on regarde cette étude ces valeurs
qui sont transmises aux filles ses
valeurs dites féminines ont des effets
beaucoup plus positif sur la société
le fils peytavin s'il est si les hommes
se comportait comme les femmes admettons
qu'ils avaient emporté des l'éducation
on change tout la société serait sans
doute plus paie plus pacifique
elle serait moins compétitives elles
seraient sans doute moins transgressive
aussi d'après ce que vous dites mais ce
qu'elle serait plus heureuse on
consommerait sans doute
beaucoup plus d'anxiolytiques on sait
que les femmes en consomment deux fois
plus que les hommes
on serait sans doute moins endettées on
mangerait plus de de fruits et de
légumes mais on n'aurait peut-être pas
découvert l'amérique on serait peut-être
jamais allé sur la lune
est-ce qu'on ne s'ennuierait pas un
petit peu alain si par s'ennuyer vous
parler du fait qu'on arrêterait de tuer
de viol et d'agresser n'ont pas d'accord
c'est parce que la dire non non bien sûr
bien sûr mais découvrir l'amérique ou
d'aller marcher sur la lune il ya une
forme à la fois il ya la compétition il
ya la transgression et à la vitesse
il ya tout ce que ce qui tout ce qui est
un facteur de risque à vos yeux
oui mais il ne faut pas confondre la
force la domination qui voilà qui
entraîne l'écrasement est effectivement
l'ambition la volonté le dépassement de
soi ça ce sont des valeurs universelles
et qui ne relèvent pas de la virilité et
ce qui pourrait changer justement si en
économiser le coût de la virilité donc
on l'a dit prêt de 100 milliards d'euros
par an c'est tout à fait colossal pour
donner un ordre de grandeur le l'impôt
sur le revenu ne rapporte seulement que
70 milliards d'euros par an à l'état
donc on pourrait investir dans des
politiques très ambitieuse par exemple
l'éradication de la grande pauvreté qui
est évalué à 7 milliards d'euros la
dette des hôpitaux qui est de 30
milliards d'euros
on pourrait augmenter de 50% le budget
de la recherche qui est lui de 50
milliards d'euros
donc on vivrait dans une société
beaucoup plus riche est également ça
changerait drastiquement le quotidien
des citoyens et des citoyennes puisque
les taux de criminalité et de
délinquance baisserait de façon
significative et donc on aurait plus
peur de marcher seul dans la rue de se
faire voler son sac de se faire agresser
dans les transports de jouer de laisser
ses enfants jouer dehors etc etc on
vivrait finalement dans une société
beaucoup plus riche et on serait tous
beaucoup plus libres parce que beaucoup
plus en sécurité et
de dire pour répondre à votre question
beaucoup plus heureux finalement est-ce
que si philippe corcuff et est encore là
j'aimerais avoir son avis qui pensent
que ça c'est vraiment une idée de gauche
réunit démence il patrice c'est une idée
progressiste non oui mais je pense qu'il
faut
comment bien dans les questions que vous
avez posé vous avez pointé que dans ce
qu'on appelle virilité il ya deux choses
et à l'imposition de la demande
domination masculine par la violence et
il y a une certaine forme qu'à prix
historiquement la curiosité le risque la
découverte et donc il faut se
débarrasser de la violence mais sans se
débarrasser du risque de la curiosité de
la découverte
c'est pour ça que moi je suis pour un
l'hybridation un d identité de ce qui a
été constituée historiquement comme
masculins comme féminins mais avec des
formes d'hybridation qui permette
l'apparition de nouvelles formes de
curiosité de nouvelles formes de
découverte de nouvelles formes
d'exploration évidemment les
explorateurs et les exploratrices
dans cet autre monde serait très
différent ariane boire vous en tant que
femme
vous trouvez ça séduisant comme comme
programme oui tout à fait moi je suis
non seulement femmes et mères de
familles nombreuses avec quatre garçons
erreurs que j'ai essayé difficilement de
les éduquer à la danse et aux balais je
me suis rendu compte que la boxe et le
parachutisme les intéressait beaucoup
plus donc j'ai dans mes plus
sérieusement je pense qu'on aurait tout
à y gagner a essayé un peu de féminiser
la société sans enlever évidemment des
valeurs qui nous porte en avant
mais qui nous permettrait à tous de
mieux vivre ensemble en tout cas ça
c'est certain
le coût de la virilité c'est le premier
essai de lucile peytavin et ça vient de
paraître chez anne carrière
[Musique]
ayhan bois vous publiez votre septième
roman l'amour au temps des éléphants
chez belfond ça commence en 1916 par
l'exécution par pendaison dans une ville
du sud des états unis d'une éléphantes
de cirque
alors c'est vraiment arrivé on va voir
la photo derrière moi qu'est ce qui
s'est passé exactement
alors en fait ce n'est pas la première
fois qu'on a exécuté un éléphant aux
états unis on en avait déjà abattu un
par balle et puis on en avait électrique
t1
c'était thomass edison qui s'en était
occupée faut se rappeler que le cirque
aux états unis dans les années 1915
c'est très important et donc il ya des
caravanes immense de cirque qui se
promènent et qui traverse tous les états
unis c'est presque en fait le seul le
loisir populaire ela en 1916 donc dans
cette petite ville des ruines qui est
vraiment un trou dans le sud des états
unis
et bien c'était les fentes mari qui est
une éléphante d'asie absolument énorme
elle pèse plus de 6 tonnes et elle n'a
pas son cornac habituel on prend
quelqu'un qui demande à travailler parce
que le cornac souffre d'une crise de
sciatique et donc la personne qu'il
remplace va en fait la brutaliser la
martyrise et lui faire mal et dans un
espèce de réflexe comme ça m'arrive à le
soulever le faire tomber et l'écrasé
vous imaginez il ya une foule qui est
venue
absolument
très heureuse à l'idée de voir des
éléphants les éléphants sont très à la
mode aux états unis on est avant d'un
beau mais l'éléphant est à la mode
et cet éléphant de la donc qui a tué et
bien il va y avoir une sorte de procès
un procès expéditif comme au moyen-age
finalement en france et on va décider de
le tuer mais c'est pas facile de tuer un
éléphant
il faut vraiment imaginer comment on
peut le tuer et donc on imagine
d'utiliser un espèce de grappins comme
ça de filins et de monter la bête
alors évidemment la première fois ça
marche pas l'éléphant va s'écraser cas
c'est cod anges les premiers spectateurs
vont assister à ce terrible spectacle
et puis la deuxième fois on va mettre
fin à la vie de marie et ce fait divers
la il a beaucoup impressionné aux états
unis il ya une foule considérable qui
est venu se déplacer et moi j'ai décidé
de commencer mon histoire par la part
cet éléphant tuer qui va mener
finalement vers d'autres éléphants plus
vivant en partant des états unis pour
arriver beaucoup plus loin en avant vos
trois héros en effet sont bouleversés
par cet événement il s'agit de deux
blancs une fille et un garçon et d'un
noir mais bon on est une époque où on
lynche elle est noire sans jugement dans
les états du sud des états unis
et donc pourquoi tout à coup les
éléphants pourquoi les éléphants à votre
avis peuvent à ce point le sort des
éléphants peuvent à ce point bouleversé
trois jeunes gens alors que le spectacle
habituel d exécution aurait pu les
sensibiliser à tout autre probable
problème alors ils sont 3 3 jeunes trois
américains ils sont rien de rien en
commun à part effectivement ce spectacle
la jeune femme qui s'appelle arabella
est infirmière et aime les éléphants
depuis sa naissance
je me suis tout à fait
vu dans ce personnage puisque les
éléphants sont mon animal favori depuis
depuis très longtemps depuis les cirques
et l'enfance jeremic et un journaliste
va avoir tout de suite l'intérêt de
l'histoire
qu'est ce qui se passe et comment la
foule va réagir
est ce que est ce que les gens vont se
passionner pour cette histoire il va
tout de suite on parlait à son journal
et pikine qui est le pauvre gosse noir
américain dont le père a été tué par des
blancs va sans doute s'identifier à ce
supplice puisque effectivement vous
l'avez dit le lynchage des noirs et et 1
est un sport national
donc ils ne se connaissent pas mais ceux
qui l'ont vu ce jour-là un mois 2 au
mois de septembre 1916 va complètement
bouleverser leur existence et ils vont
décider chacun pour des raisons
différentes de quitter les états unis
nous somme en 1916 les états unis vont
bientôt rentrer en guerre la première
guerre qui a été fait en dehors de leur
territoire
oui c'est la première guerre mondiale et
chacun tous les trois vont se retrouver
à paris en ce 8 mai mais ils ont vécu là
une boucherie colossales sans précédent
et en même temps on a l'impression que
rien ne pouvait effacer la mort de cet
éléphant de leur conscience ou de leur
subconscient
là aussi ça peut paraître étonnant se
disant non vu tellement là tous ceux qui
ont vécu cette première guerre mondiale
que ce soit comme infirmière ou comme
soldats
se dire normalement la mort aussi
épouvantable soit elle de cette
éléphante aurait dû être effacées
tout à fait mais j'ai l'impression que
finalement la mort de l'éléphant la mort
de marie la barbarie envers cet animal
va précéder la barbarie envers les êtres
humains comme si le ce qui s'était passé
avec cet animal là va annoncer pour eux
la guerre qui sévit en europe depuis
1914 mais dans lequel ils arrivent fin
1917 dans des conditions différentes
puisque jérémy est journaliste et va
donc suivre les marines les marines vous
savez ce corps américain qui finalement
va s'illustrer
pendant la première guerre mondiale et
gagné ses lettres de noblesse
arabella elle sera infirmière est
effectivement comme vous l'avez dit va
voir la boucherie de près ce qu'elle
espère être et la der des ders comme on
disait à l'époque
et puis qui doit être soldat mais pas
soldat n'importe où il va être soldat
noir dans l'armée américaine
les harley mail fighters c'est quelque
chose qui me tenait à coeur parce que
quand j'ai rencontré ces soldats noirs
je me suis dit que ça ferait un film
formidable et que l'on avait beaucoup
parler de la seconde guerre mondiale a
raison mais qu'on avait oublié peut-être
un petit peu
l'engagement des états unis pendant la
première guerre mondiale et c'est une
très belle histoire
les soldats noirs ont dû se battre
contre les allemands et l'ont fait avec
une bravoure extraordinaire dans tout
l'est de la france mais ils ont dû aussi
se battre et on le sait mois contre
l'état major américain qui ne voulait
absolument pas des soldats ne voulait
pas les reconnaître et a tout fait pour
que ses soldats la tombe dans l'oubli
donc c'était un petit clin d'oeil un
clin d'oeil de l'histoire mais c'est
vrai que l'armée américaine est restée
ségrégué comme on dit jusqu'à jusqu'à la
guerre de corée donc première et
deuxième guerre mondiale comprise dans
votre roman ariane bois vos trois héros
vont décider de libérer un éléphant de
cirque e parisien et de le 2
conduire en afrique alors d'abord est ce
que c'est possible
est-ce que c'était possible cette
époque-là de voyager avec un éléphant et
est-ce que c'était souhaitable c'est à
dire qu'un enfant un éléphant pardon qui
a connu la captivité
le cirque ou le zoo d'ailleurs est-ce
qu'on peut le remettre en liberté dans
la savane dsk une chance de survivre
alors c'est vrai que c'est un projet
complètement fou c'est un projet qui est
évidemment nous paraît là nous en 2021
complètement improbable est impossible
mais on est donc en 1918 il n'y a
absolument aucune protection des animaux
les animaux sont évidemment plutôt très
mal traités dans les cirques et dans les
eaux et notre trio donc notre trio qui
est liés par l'amitié et par l'amour va
décider donc de prendre un éléphant et
de le remettre en liberté alors c'est un
peu quelque chose d'infantile en fait
c'est comme un jeu d'enfant mais ça
fonctionne comme pas comme de manière
étonnante il à izon de l'argent grâce à
jérémy qui a hérité et ils vont utiliser
cet argent pour lutter pour affréter un
cargo et amadouer les autorités c'est
pas très difficile ils arrivent ils
arrivent à nairobi et puis ensuite ils
vont prendre la route et libéré cet
éléphant qui s'appelle cha j'ai voulu y
voir quelque chose d'un roman
d'aventurés d'un roman comme on pouvait
lire dans notre enfance avec ce fil
rouge avec ce ciment qui constitue
l'éléphant et puis l'éléphant d'asie va
s'adapter va être accueilli par les
congés ses congénères dans un troupeau
et finalement va vivre une autre vie
c'est ce qu'on essaye de faire
aujourd'hui avec des éléphants qui sont
des éléphants de cirque deux eaux on
essaye de les deux les maîtres n'ont pas
dans leur environnement naturel parce
qu'ils ne vivraient pas mais dans des
sanctuaires dans des orphelinats ou dans
des maisons de retraite ou après avoir
tellement travaillé vous savez que la
loi a changé et que heureusement les
animaux
sauvage non plus à travailler dans les
cirques et une en tout cas ne peuvent
plus être achetés pour être montré dans
les cirques et donc c'est peut-être en
1918 les premiers prémices d'un d'un
droit sur les droits des animaux et de
certaines dispositions à leur égard ayem
bois il arrive au kenya dans une colonie
britannique
vous les blancs ne sont pas du tout
garder y prennent de la cocaïne il
couche avec les autochtones il fondé par
tous alors à montparnasse dans les
années 20 je veux bien mais à nairobi
vous êtes sûrs ah oui je suis tout à
fait sûr ça s'appelle la happy valley la
vallée heureuse
ce sont les contemporains de karen
blixen et ça a été en prenant documenté
puisque ça a constitué un scandale en
angleterre il ya eu un meurtre dans
cette communauté de l'ativan et et tous
les journaux anglais se sont fait des
gorges chaudes sur ce qui se passait
dans cette happy valley avec des
personnages extraordinaires les dix huit
villes l'étranger des couples d'aristo
qui ont quitté l'angleterre et les
brumes de londres pour finalement
s'éclater sous le soleil sous le soleil
du kenya ça a duré un petit peu de temps
dans dans le siècle mais on s'en
souvient encore
et aucun lien on peut visiter leur
maison il y avait effectivement des jeux
troubles il y avait de la drogue il y
avait
des choses extrêmement amusante pour les
gens qui l'ont vécue on a des mémoires
inde et aristocratique qui les ont ils
ont rédigé
donc je me suis vraiment appuyé sur une
forte documentation pour raconter cette
happy valley et ses moeurs complètement
des cravates dépravés j'ai eu envie
finalement nous met trois personnages
soient confrontés à ça peut-être que il
peut être que l'afrique qui les a réunis
les sépara en tout cas j'avais vu un
film dans les années 80 qui s'appelait
white mischief vers la route de nairobi
qui raconte l histoire de ces aristo et
j'ai eu envie de les associer à mon
roman parce que c'est éminemment
romanesque évidemment à yann bois donc
septième roman l'amour au temps des
éléphants ça vient de paraître chez
belfond je vous remercie tous les trois
d'avoir participé à cette émission merci
de nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]